>>Narrator: It's no
surprise that the children
who attend Capitol Elementary
enjoy going to school.
This brightly colored,
sparkling new building minutes
from downtown Phoenix is a
flexible learning environment
with spacious classrooms.
Instruction here features hands-on
cooperative learning with an emphasis
on literacy and social
emotional growth.
>>Teacher: How do you think
Lisa and Corduroy feel now?
>>They happy.
>>Good answer.
>>I'm very proud of you.
This is only your fourth day
learning English at Capitol School.
And you did a great job saying--
trying to say it in English.
>>Narrator: The dedicated staff
is supported by a large group
of involved parents and a
core of community volunteers.
>>Narrator: What is surprising is
that this school exists at all.
It's a testament to the will of a
community that refused to give up
and to the vision of a
principal named Cora Garrido.
>>Cora: Good for you.
>>When I first came to Capitol,
there had been a building
that was condemned.
And at that time, a decision was
made to set up the modular units
because this was dying community.
And people didn't believe that there
were enough children in this area
to warrant giving it much attention,
and certainly not building
another facility
to accommodate the
needs of these children.
>>Narrator: The need
here is apparent.
According to the latest census,
this is the poorest
district in the country.
Every student here
qualifies for free meals.
More than half are recent immigrants
from Mexico who speak little
or no English [Women
speaking Spanish]
and while some saw the
community as a liability,
Garrido saw it as a resource.
>>Cora: We know a lot
about instruction,
but there's a whole community
out there that can help.
>>Cora: So, what we do
is we have Walk the Talk.
And the entire staff, custodians,
office staff, the nurse,
social worker we go out and
knock on our family's homes
and welcome them to the new year.
>>See you on Monday.
>>Narrator: In addition to
walking the neighborhood
on 110 degree August afternoons,
Garrido has scoured the school
district looking for help
from businesses and other potential
partners, people like Bob Kay.
>>Bob: Do you know anybody in town
that handles Gabriel
shocks for the big trucks?
>>Narrator: Kay runs a truck parts
firm a few blocks from the school
and heads up the local Kiwanis club.
He'd been volunteering at Capitol for
about a year when Garrido invited him
to join a diverse group of teachers,
students, parents, architects,
and community members who
began a year long discussion
about what they wanted
in a new school.
>>Bob: I was amazed that
they asked me to begin with.
You know, here I am a little
businessman out wandering
around doing little
businessman things.
And here I was asked to
be with bankers, lawyers,
people that I thought
were far above me.
>>He was worried about
making it a box.
And he said, "I can
remember that earlier.
Let's do it this way."
I'm glad that you didn't
get your way.
>>I am, too.
>>It was hard for me initially to buy
into that whole process because it's
like what does a parent know
about putting together a building?
As an engineer you have step
one, step two, step three.
And in this process, I was
forced to break out of that,
so I was out of my comfort zone.
>>I came at it from a
business lawyer standpoint.
For me, this was a deal.
>>Bob: My gosh, you know, when you
stop to think about 60 people all
with different attitudes and
different ideas and things.
And the most important things
is they worked as a group.
>>We stayed focused on children.
>>It wasn't about what Cora, what
Fred, or Greg, what any adult wanted.
It was for children.
>>Narrator: Ultimately,
the new school design grew
out of Capitol's commitment to
cooperative project-based learning.
>>Teacher: In a quiet buddy buzz
voice describe your carrot seeds.
>>When we began planning, we
never spoke of the facility.
We spoke of how we wanted to teach.
We wanted to teach
cooperatively within our classroom,
but also within the school,
within the grade level,
within other grade levels.
So when we decided how
we wanted to teach,
then the building just
sort of evolved.
>>You put them in the order of signs.
>>Paul: One of things that came out
of the discussions with the parents
and the rest of the design
group was the idea that many
of the children learn
in different ways.
And so the flexibility
was of key importance.
The idea of having a place to build
large scale projects and not have
to tear them down every time,
the idea of having a space
where you could have multiple
computers that if you needed them,
you had more than just a couple.
Or, if you weren't using them,
they weren't in your way,
and someone else could use them.
And a whole series of kinds
of learning that needed more
than just the basic classroom.
And so, what came out
of that was this sort
of center exploratory commons area.
>>Narrator: The school's
flexible design allows as many
as four separate classrooms
to open their sliding walls
to share a large common space often
used for collaborative projects.
At this school the curriculum
is focused on literacy,
which is delivered through a
program called Success For All.
>>Mari: It's a 90 minute
uninterrupted reading block for all
of our school, we have K through 6.
And what they do during this
time is the students are tested,
and then they're placed
according to their reading level.
>>Cooperative learning is
the foundation of the program
because we work as teams, and
we're learning to work as teams
because in real life we have to
work with different types of people.
>>Teacher: Okay, now
pair with your partner.
>>Mari: This way every
single child is engaged,
and every single child has an
opportunity to give their answers.
>>Welcome, parents, to
Family Literacy Night.
I know you're going to have fun...
>>Narrator: Capitol's parents
have a strong commitment
to their neighborhood school.
>>Teacher: What I want you to do is
go ahead and find a book you would
like to read to your parents.
>>Narrator: They come to
Parent's Literacy Night
to learn English language skills
along with their children.
>>Teacher: [speaking Spanish]
>>Narrator: They can also attend
special parent classes and offer help
on fundraisers and in the classroom.
>>Volunteer: You want
to be a nurse, doctor?
Really, that's awesome.
>>Narrator: But not all of
Capitol's homeroom parents are
actually parents.
Many of the school's volunteers are
employees of a Phoenix law firm.
>>Kent: We certainly could
have written a check to Capitol
and helped them buy
computers or books.
This was really investment of time.
We wanted our people get out from
behind their desks, down to Capitol
where they interacted with the
kids and had an opportunity
to invest themselves in the process,
as opposed to just writing a check.
For every one of us
that have participated,
education now has a very
different feel to us.
>>Nancy: The art teacher works
with us and gets pictures
to us once a month, which we
display on our second floor,
which is our client
floor, our fancy floor.
And we display the pictures.
We put the child's name up just
like we do artwork that we paid lots
of money for, with the
artist's name beside it.
>>Every first grader was in school.
Good for you.
>>Narrator: Success is
difficult to measure here.
Since a third of Capitol's student
population are the sons and daughters
of migrant workers who leave
the district every year.
>>They receive a certificate...
>>Narrator: But, Garrido
points to improved test scores
and the school's nearly perfect
attendance record as measures
of the dedication of
parents, teachers,
community members, and students.
Efforts that are recognized in
the awarding of certificates
and t-shirts to these terrific kids.
>>Bob: You can see this morning
that those little kids just beamed.
I hope that we're making a
positive difference in their lives.
And I think we are.
You know, if we save one, that's one
that we don't have to worry about.
If we save two, what a
miraculous thing that we've done.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.